[Music]
all right welcome back
so in the last lecture we defined the
complex logarithm as the inverse of the
complex exponential and we found
something a little bit uh surprising
which is that
the complex logarithm of a number z a
complex number z
actually has infinitely many values
there's not just one
logarithm of z there's a whole
infinitude or infinitely many
uh values that are equally valid for for
the logarithm of z
so in this lecture what i'm going to do
is i'm just going to give a really quick
recap of why that's true i think that
the last lecture the first time anyone
hears about the complex logarithm it's a
little confusing so i'm going to just
really really simply give a recap
but we're going to use it specifically
to answer questions
about uh things like how do you compute
you know the
the nth root
of one or the third root
of i
or more generally you know what are
these equal to or more generally if i
have some you know z to the
one quarter power
equals one what values of z will satisfy
that equation okay so this is kind of uh
the
the topic of today
and the way i'll write this
mathematically is we're going to be
looking at functions again we're talking
about functions of a complex variable
we're talking about functions
z to the power a
where a is no longer an integer we know
how to take z squared z cubed z to the
you know fourth power and so on how do i
take z
to the one third power or z to the one
nth power or z to the pyth power how do
i do things like that
and we're going to use the complex
logarithm to do it
so
maybe
the first thing i'll do is i'll tell you
how we're going to analyze these
functions because it's going to allow us
to do things like compute the n roots
of 1 or the 3 roots of i
we already know that the square root of
a number there are two square roots the
square root of 9 could be plus 3 or
minus 3. the square root of negative 1
could be plus i or minus i
similarly there are 3 cubed roots of any
complex number there are n
nth roots of any complex number z
and we're going to figure out how using
this complex logarithm formula
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to rewrite this z to the a
using exponentials and logarithms so
we're going to rewrite
essentially this may be rewritten
re-written
using
x the exponential function
and
log the logarithmic function and
specifically the way we're going to do
that is we're going to say that
z
sorry let me think uh
yeah so so z
is going to equal e
to the log
of z
log of z is infinite valued but e to
that only has one value that's that's
the way i'm going to explain this again
in a way that's less confusing so this
is definitely true because log and
exponential are inverse functions if i
take the log of z
all these values but then i exponentiate
any one of them i recover z so this is
definitely true
and so we're going to essentially use
that to show
that z to the power a
is equal to e
to the it's this to the power a which we
also know is e to the a
log of z
so we're going to take this expression
for log of z we're going to multiply it
by that
power a so a log of this plus i a times
that and we're going to see what what
falls out when we take the exponential
of that and that's how we're going to
define functions like z to the one-half
or z to the one-third or z to the
negative one-third things like that okay
now before we get into this and before
we solve for you know the square root of
i or the third root of i or things like
that i'm just going to uh very very very
quickly recap why this logarithm was
infinitely valued and why that's not
actually that confusing at all okay
so
specifically
we wanted
uh if we if we think about z
in the complex plane so z is this number
in the complex plane and it has a radius
and it has a principal angle between 0
and 2 pi just the way we always define
angles between 0
and 2 pi
if i add another 2 pi to that theta it's
exactly the same point so plus
2 pi n
is exactly the same point as long as n
is an integer so when we say n is an
element of the integers this is just a
math way of saying n is an integer
then
this z could be defined using any of
those angles let's say this was you know
30 degrees 30 degrees is fine
so is 390 degrees so you know if this
was uh
you know pi
pi sixths then pi sixths plus two pi is
also valid plus four pi is and also a
valid way of defining z we normally only
choose the principal value between zero
and two pi but i could add 2 pi to that
any any way i like
and and the the real catch here i think
what was confusing last time for me i
confused myself
is that
if i add 2 pi n to that phase angle this
value z doesn't change it's not like
there's infinitely many
you know
z's z is x plus i y there is a single
real value x and a single real value y
that uniquely defines that complex
variable z
but in the in the phase angle way of
writing it there are infinitely many
thetas that are equally valid for
getting that real x and that real y i
could use the principal theta theta pi
or i could add 2 pi add 4 pi add 6 5 pi
just because there's different ways of
writing it in the complex plane doesn't
mean there are infinitely many z's
there's just
there's just a z it's a it's a complex
number it's a it's a real thing that
exists and it has you know there's one
value z
but when i compute the logarithm
specifically so that the logarithm is
the inverse of the exponential function
now
all of those many many ways of writing
that phase angle in terms of adding
multiples of 2 pi
are all valid for this this complex
logarithm because the logarithm of z is
specifically log of uh the magnitude of
z sometimes we call this the radius this
is just you know r
plus i times
any angle that if i took e to this angle
you know it would it would recover z
and now all of these infinitely many uh
angles are all valid because if i took e
to this number for any integer n i would
recover a z
now even though there is only one z
in the first place there really are
infinitely many
log of z's this is you know u
plus
i v
and these actually are different v's
it's not like here where just going
around i get to the same place the same
exact z value here if i add two n pi i
have a new v v is actually two pi and
bigger you know so so so there's
this number
w equals
actually changes when i when i rotate
around you know and i add 2 pi to this
phase angle of z
so so i think that that's where it gets
really interesting to me
is that
this input variable z is uniquely
defined it has one value this is one
value
but the logarithm
there are many many values for this v
that when i took e to that u plus iv i
would recover z and these are actually
different values v in that complex
logarithm the way we drew it before
was you know this is the
z plane the w's that are valid are all
on this line real w
equals log
of the radius
but then i have many many values
for this v term for this phase angle
here that are all
valid so there's the principal theta
but then plus 2 pi plus 4 pi you know
plus 6 pi 8 pi 10 pi minus 2 pi and so
on and so forth
so i just wanted to clear up it's not
that weird that this complex logarithm
is multi-valued it's a it's a property
of the fact
that there are many ways
of writing this phase angle i could add
2 pi i as many times as i like to this
phase angle
and this value of z doesn't change
but those are all valid logarithms
of z
good so we're going to use that property
that this is infinite value that this is
true for any integer n
to define you know what is the cubed
root of z what is the square root of z
the fourth root and so on and so forth
the nth root of z
so we're gonna we're gonna you know for
example example this could be uh
you know for example
e g for example
z to the one half
is the square root of z
so you know if a was one half i'd be i'd
be computing the square root of z
things like that so i want to define
what these functions are we know what z
to a an integer is what is z to a
fraction like one half or two thirds or
something like that
okay
good
and this is the basic formula we're
going to use to
to define
that quantity
now before i actually take this
logarithm and plug it into this formula
i want to give you an example i want to
give you an example of what is the cubed
root of one okay because i think this is
something that everybody's going to
understand and it's a pretty pretty
simple concept
so i'm going to draw
my
how do i want to do this i'm going to
draw my complex plane
and i'm going to draw the so so here's
the problem we're going to solve we're
going to say
cubed root of 1 equals what
okay so that's another way of saying you
know z
to the one third is our function
and z equals one so we're we're trying
to understand the function z to the one
third power
and we're evaluating that at z equals
one what are the values that are valid
for for z to the one third
now we kind of know already
that
one of the cubed roots of one is one
because one to the cubed you know to the
third power is one
so i know that one
of the cubed roots of one is going to
equal one
and i'm going to call that
e
to the zero we know that one equals e to
the zero that's just saying radius
equals one
theta equals zero this is e to the
whatever i zero if you like e to the
zero
but what's interesting
is that
if i took
how do i want to write this
let's say that this number
the cubed root
of one let's call that um
you know
let's call that uh
q just just to be cute
so we're saying
q cubed equals one
and so i know that e to the 0 is one
solution
e to the i 0
but i'm going to claim that 2 pi n
i can add 2 pi n to that
uh and that's also
going to to equal
uh one when i cube it so
let me uh let me let me show you i'm
going to draw the picture then we're
going to derive this i think this will
make it this will make it easier to
understand
so
if i i'm just going to draw the answer
because i think i want to show you and
then explain
these are the other
two cubed roots of one there are three
numbers that if i cube them
i will get one
which means specifically this angle here
this theta
so so so this e to the zero this is the
principal cubed root of one
but if i take you know two
pi
divided by three
and add that to the phase angle that's
another cubed root of one still radius
one but now my this is the phase angle
if i take
if i take a number you know q equals e
to the i 2 pi thirds
and i cube it
q cubed
is e to the i
2 pi thirds times 3 is 2 pi and what's e
to the i 2 pi
well it's e to the 0. i got back to
where i started so if i take this wedge
times 3 i get back to where i started so
this is also a cubed root
of 1.
and then similarly
this one here which is four
pi thirds is also a cubed root uh q
let's call this um
you know this is the the second one the
third one is e to the i
4 pi thirds again if i take this number
and i take it to the third power q 3
cubed
i get e to the i
4 pi which again what is e to the i4 pi
it's e to the 0 because if i go around
2 pi twice i'm right back where i
started
and so you can kind of imagine if i take
this angle 4 pi thirds and i this is you
know
this is q
q squared would get me here and q cubed
would get me back to a phase angle of
zero
so these are all
totally valid cubed roots of one i can
have e to the zero
e to the
let's write this very very explicitly e
to the i
to pi
thirds that's this point
this is e to the i 4 pi thirds
now you might think well why isn't there
a fourth cubed root of one why why can't
i do this again
and the reason i can't do it again
is because i'll write it in red because
it's an invalid solution
if i said q equals
e to the i let's try to do 6 pi
thirds well what is e to the i 6 pi
thirds that's just e to the
i
2 pi
which is e to the 0. so e to the 0
is e to the i 6 pi thirds and so once i
go around
again and i can't i can't do 8 pi
because this is again this is also e to
the i 8 pi thirds and this is e to the i
10 pi thirds e to the i 12 pi thirds e
to the i 14 pi thirds 16 pi thirds 18 pi
thirds and so on and so forth so
even though i can keep adding 2 pi over
and over and over eventually those cube
roots start to be the same thing they
all mean the same thing there's only
three unique cubed roots of one
okay
so i'm going to
derive the general formula and then
we're going to revisit this
again
so this is actually really fun and i
think kind of illustrative to start just
playing around just like pick some
complex number you know i and compute
all of its fourth roots pick a complex
number you know
one plus i and compute all of its ninth
roots or its fourth roots or whatever
it's very very helpful to understand
what's happening here okay
so i wanna just uh
we're gonna revisit this but the basic
idea is that the cubed root of one there
are three values because there are three
unique phase angles that if i cube them
i'll get all the way back to e to the
zero or you know e to the two pi or e to
the four pi
and there are only three unique values
because if i keep doing that trick i
basically reinvent these three solutions
that i've already discovered there's
only three unique solutions
um why don't we do the same thing for
negative one let's just let's just do
this again just to make sure we
understand
so
let's try you know what is the cubed
root of negative one we should be able
to do the cubed root of negative one the
cubed root of i anything we want
so again um
okay negative one is one of the
principal cube roots of negative 1
because negative 1 times negative 1
times negative 1
equals negative 1. so this is already
one of the cubed roots
and this is e to the i
pi right i've gone pi to get here
and this is what we call the principal
cube root of negative one
and again what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take 2 pi thirds and i'm going
to add 2 pi thirds to this so 2 pi
thirds gets me here
and i'm going to add 4 pi thirds which
gets me here and if i added 6 pi thirds
i'd rediscover this point again if i
added 8 pi thirds 10 pi thirds 12 pi
thirds so there's only three unique
versions of this
this is e to the i
pi
plus two pi thirds
this is e to the i pi
plus four pi
thirds
and again this is you know also equal to
e to the i
pi plus
6 pi thirds
and so on so these are kind of it
repeats at some point
and these are the unique cubed roots of
negative 1. you can easily verify that
if i took this number and i cube it
right let's just take this number cubed
this
cubed equals e
to the i
three pi
plus four pi
which is equal to e to the i seven pi
but if i go around you know seven pi
times it's the same as just going around
e to the i pi
so this to the third power gets me where
i want to go
similarly this to the third power
you know it'll go around i think instead
of seven it'll be three plus eight is
eleven it'll go around you know and get
me to e to the i pi so these are the
principal cubed roots it's really easy
to verify once you've found one of these
it's really easy to verify you just take
the cube of that and see if it's the
number you want
okay
good so now i'm going to derive a
generic formula for this um
which is
and then maybe i'll do you know the cube
root of i just because it's really
useful to see
one of those cases as well
so the idea here is
we're going to use this expression
and then we're going to show that uh out
of all of these infinitely many values
of log only
some of them are unique when i'm taking
z to the power a
okay maybe i'll use yellow here
so let's as kind of a general example
let's take a rational
rational a and by irrational a i
literally mean it's the ratio of two
integers so this equals m over n
we say that this is an element of the
set of rationals that's just what in the
set of rationals means
which is a subset of real numbers like
pi and e and 3 and negative 2.
uh and what we mean is that m and n are
both
integers so this is the ratio of two
integers this is just the mathy way of
saying it
then what we're going to say is that z
to the power m over n
equals e
to the m over n
log
of z
and i'm going to use this whole
expression here and plug it in
and so that's going to mean i have e
to the m over n
uh
log of radius
plus i
m over n
times
my theta principle
any 2 pi sorry i this is a different n
here let's just we'll use k times any
integer times 2 pi
right so this is uh
just m over n times the logarithm of z
okay
and i'm going to break this up into the
real part the magnitude part and the you
know cosine and sine part
and so this equals
e to the m over n
log of r this is only one value there's
only one value here so
i was taking the third root of one
if i took the third root of eight
then the i would have to take the third
then the radius of that would be the
third root of of eight okay so if i took
the third
root of eight
that would be
you know the the magnitude of that would
be the third root of the magnitude of
eight so that would be two
or
2 times e to the i
2 pi thirds or 2 e to the i for
pi 3 so this is just the magnitude part
if i didn't you know if i had something
that was non-trivial magnitude like
length eight instead of length one i'd
have to take the third root of that
length as well
okay so there's that times e to the i
i'm gonna break this up i'm gonna say
this is e to the
i
m over n theta p
times e to the i
uh
m over n 2 pi
k
okay that's all i've done is i've just
taken z to the uh
m over n i've used this formula for it
and i've plugged in the complex
logarithm and i've gotten these
now
this term
is single valued
and this term is single valued
this term is true for any integer k k1
k2 k3 k0 and so forth
and so now what we're trying to do
is we're trying to find
you know
there are
only so many unique values of this
quantity before it starts repeating on
itself which is what we saw here
so um
for example if uh you know if m over n
equals 1 3
then this would be
equal to
e to the 1 3
log of r
which is the same as
r to the one third
this would be e to the i
theta p over third
over three
and this would be e to the i
two pi k over 3.
and what i claim is that there are three
unique values of k
where this is is unique so let's try k
equals zero
then this is
e to the i
zero
that's fine
k equals one
that would be e to the i
two pi thirds
that's one of my principal
uh cubed roots of one that's fine this
is different than e to the zero that's
these are different numbers
k equals two would be e to the i four pi
over three again that is a different
number than either of these two this is
an actual different complex number than
these guys okay but when i go to k
equals 3
i come back to where i started if k
equals 3 here i have e to the
i
6 pi thirds which is e to the
you know 2 pi i which is the same as e
to the 0.
e to the 2 pi is e to the 0. this is
this is the same as k equals 0.
and i'll just show you you know k equals
is e to the goodness gracious 8 pi
thirds you know i
8 pi thirds which again is the same as e
to the i
2 pi thirds these are the same number
it's just you know you just
you've gone all the way around
and so what this means is that there are
only three
unique values of k where these numbers
are actually different k equals zero k
equals one and k equals two and for all
of the other k's
you've essentially just gone around and
re-found this number or re-found this
number or re-found this number you know
and over and over again
so so i think that that's really really
interesting that kind of shows why
and if this was one-fourth there would
be four unique numbers before you get
back to where you started if this was
one-fifth there would be five unique
numbers before you get back to where you
started and that's why there are three
unique cube roots of a complex number
there are four unique fourth roots of a
complex number
and so on and so forth okay it's
literally because this complex logarithm
when you divide when you when you
multiply it by this rational number
there are exactly n
unique values of k that give you
different numbers for this quantity here
after which it starts recycling back on
itself
okay i think that's super duper useful
and this means i can take the fourth
root of i i can take the ninth root of
one plus i i can take any complex number
i like
and if i write it in polar form with a
principal angle
and i use this formula for the logarithm
i can find every single nth root
of this complex number i can take z to
the one nth or the two nth or three nth
or whatever and i can find all n unique
roots of that
of that number
sometimes these are called um
there's a a saying in complex numbers
called the roots of unity the the third
root of one the fourth root of one the
fifth root of one because they form
these kind of canonical
pictures that you can use to compute
other roots of other numbers
good um
this actually begs the question there's
some really weird stuff that happens if
you take
z to the
uh
a rational number if i take you know if
i take z
to the
the pyth power this is an irrational
number there is not there is not an
integer m and n that i can write
pi in terms of
and so if i take like you know
negative one to the pi power
there are
infinitely many this is super weird
there are infinitely many values of
negative one to the pyth power
because for every single k
you know for every single n here for
every single k here if i if i plug in a
pi here
there are infinitely many values of this
and in fact i would say that any number
here
on the unit circle is a solution of
negative 1 to the pi power that's a very
weird and strange outcome of the fact
that log of z is infinite valued and pi
is irrational it's a weird thing but
it's true
um
good what else do i want to say uh maybe
i'll just do a couple more examples
because i think this is really helpful
um
let's see let's see let's see okay
i'm just going to erase this
because i actually like this formula
better
uh let's do the
fourth root of i and then we'll call it
quits okay so if i take uh sorry for the
squeaky pen
so let's say
i have
or let's take you know the fourth root
of
16i because i want to show you what
happens if you have a non you know if
it's not length one
so in this case um
let's write 16i
is equal to 16
e to the i
pi halves okay
so the number i
is just
e to the i pi halves because it's in the
pi halves angle
and 16 i has a radius of 16. so this is
the radius
and this is you know e to the i theta
principle theta principle is pi halves
and so if i want to take the fourth root
of 16i
i basically take you know r to the one
fourth
and then e to the i theta p to the one
times e to the i two pi k fourths for
all integer k until it recycles on
itself okay so the radius to the
one-fourth
equals
two i chose 16 because it's fourth root
is two
uh so the magnitude of all of these
fourth roots they're going to have
radius two
uh this is e to the i
pi eighths okay because that's what the
principal angle divided by eight is
and this is really easy to understand if
i took this uh you know this is let's
say
let's say this is
16i
then the
first principal six uh four through to
this
is gonna have
i'm gonna divide this into four pieces
so it's going to have length 2
e to the i
pi 8 because if i took this to the
fourth power i would get 2 to the fourth
is 16
and e to the pi 8 to the 4th power is e
to the i pi halves
which is this thing this is
you know 16 e to the i
pi halves so this is my first
principal
4th root of 16i
but now
i also have
this
plus
2 pi
fourths plus 4 pi fourths plus 6 pi
fourths
and so on and so forth so uh
e to the i
and i'm just going to say you know 2 pi
fourths is pi
has
pi halves k and i'm going to choose k
until this thing recycles on itself so k
equals zero
k equals one k equals three
can't count this has been a long day
k equals three and k equals four
so at k equals 0 i just have 2
e to the i pi
8 that's the solution here
for k equals 1 i have
e
to the i pi 8 plus i pi halves so that's
i
five pi eighths
for k equals two and and five pi is just
this
plus pi halves which is a little hard
for me to draw but it's something like
that
uh if i have k equals 2
then this is 2
e
to the i pi 8 plus
pi which is goodness that's going to be
i 9 pi 8. i'll do k equals 3 is 2 e to
the i
uh probably 13 pi
8. and by the time i get to k equals 4
i'm going to get 2 e to the i
uh
add 4 again i'm going to get 17 pi
8 which equals e to the i
pi
8.
so by the time i get to k to the 4th k
and the 5th and the sixth and the
seventh and the eighth here
i essentially have rediscovered the same
numbers
uh that i was using originally
so for k equals zero that's this one for
k equals one it's this one k equals to
each of these i'm just adding pi halves
i'm just rotating by 90 degrees this is
just you know 90 degrees or pi halves so
the next one is going to be here and the
last one is going to be here
and what's really cool is that all of
these nth roots of any number kind of
form this star pattern where they all
are equal distant to each other dividing
360 degrees
so these you know were each 120 degrees
separate or
two pi thirds separate each of these are
90 degrees or
pi halves separate and at some point
there are only four unique fourth roots
of of this number because after the
fourth unique one the next one i'm
basically back where i started
and if this was the fifth
you know nth root i would get a star
pattern with five you know like a
pentagon i would get things equal spaced
five ways if i took the sixth root i
would get things equal spaced six ways
and so on and so forth so it's really
cool there's this kind of geometric
picture
but this is all related to the fact that
the complex logarithm
is infinite valued
uh and so you can use that when you're
computing z to a fractional power like
the square root of i or the cubed root
of negative one or whatever you like
okay i would recommend practicing this
try this out you can basically do this
for any number z
uh you can try this out and you can
figure out where this thing recycles
okay thank you